if you want to raise money need to raise
money are trying to figure out how to
raise money this is probably one of the
best fundraisers I know so buckle up Mr
Peter
fam so Peter and I met a couple years
ago we were in Puerto Rico at a
conference I don't know if I really
cared about the conference or he did I
don't know how either one of us got
there we looked at each other and we
said hey you want to go get dinner we
went and got dinner and about three
o'clock in the morning we were like man
we're still not at dinner but we are
dancing drinking having a blast all
throughout Puerto Rico um and somehow we
stayed friends which uh may be a
testament to you um and along the way
I've watched you do some incredible
things um you run a product studio for
those that don't know science um is
probably the leading product studio in
the country and you guys have incubated
Dollar Shave Club Liquid death many many
other companies
can you just tell us the Dollar Shave
Club story first specifically between
great marketing great product and
funding something that was different and
you had to do a lot of work I think to
kind of make sure that you guys had the
capital you needed to scale that to a
billion dollar business uh yeah so
raising money it turns out I'm just
really good at it I I think put the
microphone like that raising money is
fairly easy to me now mostly because
it's a repetition right I've had
somewhere between seven eight 8,000 NOS
at this point in the way uh science
works I've run Venture fund La I help
our Founders raise money so we're
basically helping them co-found the
business they move into the offices and
it's a grind and so Dollar Shave Club
friend of a friend uh introduced us
Michael Dubin and we'll get to liquid
death similar story he worked at an
agency Super Creative had this crazy
idea um through a random friend of a
friend ended up with a lit Warehouse
full of razor blades that was being
stored at a
Church um and I think the you got to we
could wind back the clock a little this
is nobody had ever shipped there was
subscription did not exist on online
right it was built on Magento so this is
pre- Shopify right this is like stripe
had just started and nothing existed for
consumers buy stuff online to get
shipped to the house so here's the pitch
Dollar Shave Club today people go to
razors at the CVS and $30 it's locked
behind a cabinet you feel like a
criminal but now on SF if I guess you
buy eggs it's behind you know locked and
we're going to ship to Consumers direct
but humor drives everything so my basis
of everything is always culture and he
is just funny and creative in that video
that original cost
$6,500 right and YouTube just this is
like early YouTube days and the ideas
was like well can we drive our reality
let's put the video on the
homepage him and I actually argued to
like 5: in the morning on launch day
homepage autoplay homepage autoplay he's
like absolutely not absolutely not 6: in
the morning he relents he put on the
homepage it autop plays it crashes the
servers and that like that was the
moment right it's like that's for me the
moment and understanding like okay
social drives Commerce so back then the
idea of raising money for the video and
selling raisal BS online we got NOS
everywhere Kiron green at Forerunner she
hadn't even closed her fund yet I begged
her to invest
Eileen who essentially is Cowboy
Ventures now she was at Kleiner begged
her invest 250 250 I didn't syn it
Felisa Ventures like these are some of
the best firms today begged he put in
100 the rest was like begging and
stealing 50,000 50 to raise the first
million and and I probably went through
75 to 80 Nos and like these were
personal friends of mine trust me this
is going to work this is going to work
so that first million right and so it's
one of these things where you just got
to hit it over and over and over and I
now raising money for me is it is not
personal when someone says no it's just
not for them that's okay like music I
went I was at gospel last night tillar
they Clos at 4:30 I don't know
why you the dance the music or you don't
right you hear a song you're like oh who
is that I I want to listen to again
Who's the artist put on my playlist but
then you hear song like that's not for
me like Metallica is not for me they are
clearly the one of the best heavy metal
bands in the world that's okay and I
don't want that investor so it when
people say no that's okay wake up
there's always another another another I
know you were out late because I was in
the WhatsApp group while you were
planning and then I saw I got removed at
12:30 while I was sleeping
I was like damn there's still planning a
lot in there I guess for me it was only
1:30 technically I'm from La so um let's
talk liquid death I think a similar
story and uh what's interesting is you
called me and you were like Hey we're
going to do water in a can and I said
Peter I love you uh no that's stupid and
then you were like no pump seriously
like trust me and I was like H let me
think about it and then I saw you in uh
Austin Texas South by Southwest uh plint
and I were both there and you literally
had a cooler
of liquid death that you were carrying
around and you were handing them out to
people and I'll never forget we were in
a bar and you handed one to both of us
um she drinks slow so we were leaving
the bar she still had hers and we went
to leave and the bouncer was like hey
you can't leave with alcohol and it hit
me I was like holy every single
person is going to think this is alcohol
but it's actually water and then you
explain kind of the social component of
you want to look cool at the bar you
don't want to have the Dan bottle blah
blah whatever what was was that
fundraising experience like CU it took
me multiple times in a personal
relationship and you basically twisting
my arm and then I finally I was like I
had um so I was an angel investor in
ring and Jamie simov I called and I said
if you invest I it's the only person I
did it for because he made me he made me
money yeah you didn't offer me this deal
go ahead and I said if you invest I will
personally guarantee that you will not
lose money I will I will write a check
out of my pocket if if this thing
doesn't work please invest and so
I knew so my thing is about culture
which is honestly why I excuse why I go
out last night is understanding in the
moment when I got pitched this idea you
I was doing this similar talk for
Snapchats accelerator so Spiegel asked
me to like they were doing early days of
their accelerator hey talks to
entrepreneurs how to raise money and uh
Sky Michael who was running the
accelerator said hey there's a company
that applied it's not for us it's for
Snapchat but I think you'd like it
liquid death here's their Facebook page
and it was just a three it's a this
image of a can on a Facebook page and a
fan page and people are just commenting
how stupid it was this is idiotic Etc
and I just knew it was going to work
mostly because I had the experience of
of Dollar Shave Club but Comedy Works it
was just is this video where someone's
like liquid death it murders your thirst
but here's how water kills you water
boarding surfing drowning like people
die with water all the time let's do
liquid death it's just this funny
commercial where at the end of
it she's waterboarding somebody right
dark humer obviously and but we just
banned plastic
straws the Atlantic had just wrote an
article on how China's up buying our
trash anymore to recycle plastic bottle
water bottles to me were like the Next
Generation cigarette butt it's like e
why and I don't drink right as much as I
dance I just don't drink and I think we
did just become legal in Denver I was
like H psychedelics like friends are
doing shrooms ready and MDM like party I
I go to EDM it's like nobody's doing
alcohol it'll work pitching liquid death
can that's insane like it it just didn't
make sense to people because it's a $2
can of water but for me but on once I
had invested I think that maybe because
I was paying more attention but also
they started to kind of figure out like
they literally were building a cult and
we've heard from a couple people in
terms of like really really doubling and
tripling down on the people who believe
and so people were getting tattoos they
were taking the haters comments and
turning them into rock songs like they
really went and were like we are going
to build something that people feel an
emotional connection yeah it's if you
look at today's culture we have two
sides right people just automatically
pick a side just like human nature and
if you know what you are and you own it
people respect that way way more right
and you pick that side we picked one
side like it's funny you know
who's our audience people who don't take
themselves seriously that's it some
people take themselves too seriously and
they they don't like it that's okay and
so Mike
Cesario Dollar Shave Club right this is
liquid death also of Mike both worked at
an agency both did creative work both
had this crazy idea while working at a
creative agency say hey all he did was
he was making these commercials for like
brands that were good for you but it was
always extrems and grass and it's like
why is Red Bull and Taco Bell and in
Mountain Dew just like the wor worst
thing for you in the world but like
exciting why don't we make something
good for you but exciting and also by
the way if you think about the biggest
impact that Tesla like it's like my
stretch is always Tesla the biggest
impact is they made electric cars cool
and guess what every Manufacturing in
the world is now making electric cars
we're making beverage and can cool water
so it's not that look we'll sell
hundreds of millions of cans and
eventually billions of cans but Coke and
Pepsi Prett produce like a billion
plastic bottles a day right so
culture to your point why this over time
the seed round million dollars big still
look at at this point I have a fund so
we funded it and every single round got
harder and harder and then it got easier
like everything else right and what I
say is fundraising is the world used to
look like this so the tips of always
fundraising is format is the world used
to be like
this the world now has
this I'm building the things that's
taking advantage of this and this is how
the world will be over here right so
think repeat this again so this is the
format that you guys use in the pitches
and in the decks and just for context
when I say that Peter is one of the best
fundraisers I know any major Venture
fund is probably invested in one of the
companies uh literally he many times
goes and raises the money not the CEO of
the business because he is so good at
doing it and it's the same exact formula
every single time yeah my favorite was I
was in bench I was sitting at we were
raising for dog V and um Benchmark and
Bill Gurley looks at me and goes Peter
what are you doing in the meeting like
like you know what you're doing he
Aaron's firsttime founder like I'm here
to translate like half the questions you
ask he doesn't even understand right and
Bill girl eventually invested was on the
board we merged with Rover it's now
public but it it's a communication right
they're asking questions I can read it I
know exactly what's happening in the
room what questions why they're saying
no I can read a no a mile away it's
always but think of all the biggest
companies in the world it was before
Uber right it was well the people call
taxis but because of cell phone and GPS
and a smartphone I can now hit a button
and then people cars will come and and
because of eBay because of this idea of
an anonymous person but well we'll have
five star reviews this person I'm going
to start trusting right I actually think
about like Ubers and the door Dash and
lifts actually eBay started it oh this
Anonymous person lots of reviews five
stars I'll send money and they might
send me stuff Uber was the same thing
right and so this is now how the world
looks liquid death well look plastic
water bottles
alcohol the world now doesn't want
plastic they don't drink they want
something fun and it turns out the
Insight of this and I've handed out
personally somewhere between 8 and 9,000
cans out of my hand is that when you
hold it people talk to you that's it
when you hold this oh what's that this
is either the stupidest idea in the
world oh my God that is so dumb or it's
funny and it's awesome right and that's
it and so this stranger we're not
talking about the weather anymore we're
not like what you do during lockdown
like what's your startup what do you do
which is terrible
question we're talking about something
funny and now like human that human
interaction of haha funny connection
well pavlovian response is when I'm at a
concert right where the official
waterfall Live Nation when I go to the
concession stand I'm just you're just
thirsty you're not actually caring what
when I grab a Coke nobody talks to me
grab Bud Light definitely nobody talks
to me I grab a liquid I always meet
somebody funny and it's fun why not so
that right so cultural Insight so
telling that story and showing people
and the
reaction that's how you kind of get the
story told in fundraising is how the
world was how the world is now what's
happening and how am I taking advantage
of that moment this is the way world's
going to look now the secret of all
fundraising seed otherwise usually past
seed seed is I'll say the the the worst
thing for your pitch is numbers like
like like everything is worse once you
actually have Revenue because now have
much Reven let do multiples and this do
discount of cash FL like storytelling of
a story right it's all about
storytelling and if you tell people I
hate this like oh in I'm a seed company
here's my Revenue in five years like I
know you're making up
like why are we making why are we making
up right tell me a bigger story in
fact you might be limiting yourself so
what the secret is you say oh I'll be
doing $100 million in two years like so
now as an investor I'm like oh so that's
cap what if that's too small for me we
have this whole story about Masa and
SoftBank that's way too small let me
give me the tools for my imaginator my
imagination to run wild and oh my
God he does he doesn't know what I know
and if I invest oh it's going to be so
much bigger than that person knows that
that makes me feel like I want to invest
right does that make sense like I'm
almost in a way kind of taking advantage
of Young Buck over here let me give some
money and he doesn't know what he's got
but if you if you tell me what you got
and like I get to judge like H too
small I was in fundraising there's three
things people always Focus for me is
always always tell people focus on the
three things meaning you have a current
business whatever it is if you are in
the moment where you actually have users
acquisition retention Revenue strip
yourself back as a founder and say three
things that go up and to the right when
I say up to the right it's this L this
is what I call linear is flat linear
flat
is I'm doing $100,000 in Revenue a month
every month I'm like great call me back
in 12 months and you do 1.2 million well
it'll compan be more expensive of course
that's fine I will you're telling me I'm
going reduced my Risk by
99% right I reduced my RIS and PID 2x
all day but if I tell you my Revenue was
well six months ago was $100,000 and
four months ago is 250 last month's like
800 I I I can't mathematically calculate
what's happening in 12 months so I have
to I have to invest now does that make
sense so but it doesn't always have to
be Revenue look at things so hold on
these are like insights that he can
unpack very deeply um
the idea of creating urgency by having
charts that go up and to the right money
and it doesn't have to be Revenue it be
correlated re it can be correlations so
um Enterprise sales well it used to take
me six months to close a sale six months
ago six months you took six months three
months ago we got it down to like a
month last week dude people are like
clicking on a button and signing up
automatically without talking to me whoa
something right like something's
happening every scenario is like well um
users used to use the product six months
ago they'd come in and they use the
product for like two minutes three
months ago 12 minutes last week like 48
minutes I don't know what's happening
like you tell them what's happening but
in a way right you're showing like if I
give you
money if I as an investor give you money
what's your job to get smarter and
faster right and what's great is as as
an investor oh you took you took his
money and got smarter and faster and I
get to jump on the coattails of that
make sense so it makes me feel like oh
okay I didn't do it the last round and
instead of me thinking oh that investor
got a better price than me it's like no
no no I got I'm riding the backs of that
last investor who took all the risk and
that Founders now figured a lot of
out and if I give them more money that
means they're going to continue this
acceleration path of figuring it it's
faster so Vel I call velocity any metric
in your business doesn't matter doesn't
have to not be Revenue anything that has
velocity right so Enterprise sales to
Consumer products it used to take X
right six months used to take this long
to do this
thing three months ago and a month ago
and I was still finders for the next 30
days if you just do that thing manually
I don't care if you got to go flyer cars
and talk to people you need to increase
your r attention call your customers
investor didn't know that you physically
called every customer they just I don't
know people just start coming back like
do the hard work right and I think cat
said the thing do the hard work you
better know the entire stack the whole
experience but find little gaps in that
business where you can say the whole
team's going to focus on getting people
to spend more money forget new customers
I want to
know people who spent money last month
did they come back did they refer a
friend fine Comm everyone refer 6 months
ago 2% people would refer a friend three
months ago fifth you know four last week
I don't like 30
40% acceleration velocity velocity
because it doesn't have to tie to the
revenue so there's the story of
acceleration but what about the visual
yes in the deck which is I think one of
your greatest hacks explain this so
right linear is flat meaning like I said
100,000 200 right cumulative C like I
can predict this that acceleration curve
six months ago it used to take this long
speed speed speed and all of a sudden
think oh my gosh like if I don't invest
right now I in three months they're
going to figure that out and the
conversion is going to go to 70% right
in like it'll be such an obvious
investment I can't miss out fomo is
real if this goes to the point of when
you read a room and investors if they do
not respond in 24 hours they're not
interested think about all like if you
met somebody out last
night if they Tech they don't text you
in a for a month are they interested in
you no of course not like if they're
liking your Instagram post like that
night that's
good right and that I take any signal I
will take any signal of investor
interest within 2 4 hours it could be a
retweet it could be they checked out my
LinkedIn profile ideally they actually
email me thanking me asking me follow
for what questions right the reality is
when investors say oh it's too early oh
you know come back when you're there's
just not just trying to be nice right or
24 hours we're not that busy well I am
most BCS they're not that busy think
about it how many Investments do they do
the year you're telling me you do six a
year and if you're really really
interested you can't like text me email
something the next day that you're right
they're not the moment you left the room
they stop thinking about you so they're
done don't waste your time move on and
so that's the pace is like don't get
drowned out and Chase and spend so
people spend so much time chasing the no
it's not going to happen move on right
then you start just like everything else
in the real world you start looking
desperate game over all right so
you know you want to go fundraise you
come up with a story right you've walked
us through that formula uh you make your
deck deck looks pretty anyone who wants
a hack the number one fomo metric in uh
any deck you can put your little bar
chart and then just put a big fat
arrow on top of it and really
Hammer home this shit's going to the up
and to the right works like a charm you
can even people are gonna get mad
squeeze it remember in college where
you'd like widen the margins and so
that you could get that three-page paper
when you really only wrote two and a
half you can do the same thing yeah look
humans are stupid and they're like oh
wow that's a really steep curve it's all
storytelling right now of course people
always say it's not fraud you just have
to tell the story find the things in
your business that are just moving
faster whether you you know it used to
take you months to recruit somebody and
it's fast everything's just f everything
just feels faster in the business and
again let me make the you know this
connection like user growth is connected
to this velocity that's really Happ
they're figuring it out in the business
it doesn't matter what it is but there
are moments in the
business if you focused on it you can
show me this like G especially this room
is all early stage seed there's no
numbers you have no numbers nothing
ruins a raise better than numbers like
just remember that nothing ruins a raise
better than numbers the moment you have
users it's like great customer
acquisition costs retention like I just
start digging in on that actual number
but you start talking about your user
experience and how again you're you're
getting smarter and faster around that
customers getting to that customer or
driving the time it takes for customers
to consider the purchase right or the
time it takes for them to refer the time
to renew the number of cancellations got
reduced whatever it is like these are
the things forget the top thing focus on
the underlying part of the business and
then less is more every deck I see every
single deck D
knows like 20% less words that's it like
nobody wants to read it's a telephone
game if you pitch me no matter what I
need to tell somebody I need to tell
somebody the story and if it's a lot of
words I'm not going to remember it like
it's just and then I start feeling
stupid so think about that Telephone
Game means when I go home really I'm out
at networking I talk to my colleagu I'll
talk to my significant other I talk to
my partners I need to explain why I'm
excited about this deal and if it's not
simple couple people pitched me I'm like
what does it do and they're using all
these buzzword Buzz words like I don't
what do you do how do I explain the
elevated pitch is really about if you
can get a
concise I can then go tell somebody else
that's it just remember telephone game
is they have to tell somebody else if
they can't tell their partner what why
they're doing the deal what the company
is they're not going to do the deal and
the moment they feel stupid again the
moment they feel dumb because someone
says why about this they don't have the
answer they're like oh yeah you're right
it's not that good of a idea anyways so
simplify less
words the deck just short ADHD use chat
GPT for God's sakes just like shorten
the thing up bullet points how the world
used to be this is what I'm taking
advantage of and this is the way I look
at the
world here's why I'm a badass this goes
back to early stage super early stage
the founder the founder the founder your
product will evolve why are you a
badass like tell people why are you
badass and why is here's why is your
team a badass and that tells me that
you're going to be figuring out
like like you will not survive if you
can't figure things out I I met uh NBA
player last night it's like I love
athletes Olympians think about Olympians
they train
con like their whole lives for this one
day and then they're done and wait four
years resilience is it's like resilience
has to show up in that personality trait
right cat yesterday like talking about
resilient that inspiration is like oh
instantly tell me your story why and
then everything else like doesn't really
so much matter because if you tell me
your story why you and then show me that
you're St when people give you money you
figure out you're smart you figure
it out faster faster faster it's like
okay that that's somebody has your
back once you have the deck the story
the great
graphics what's the process how do you
create fomo how how do you make sure
you're talking to enough investors like
what does that look like it's changed I
think postco because of Zoom so it used
to be that i' flop to S Hill and you can
only I kind of knew everybody every firm
I and it's like red points next to
sequoia's office and ivp's upstairs got
menal over I can schedule them 15
minutes apart drive across street to
Jason like like this is Loop but now on
Zoom the assumption is well you do a
call every 30 45 minutes remember the
investor you also have to remember which
also means the investor that you're
pitching has a little bit more fomo
these days because the assumption
is once I hang up this Zoom this person
is pitching 10 15 20 people a day right
all over the world
so the process for me is still
relatively pitch early call it
friendlies people that you you probably
wouldn't take their money they're not
that great but like they're going to ask
some good questions some dumb questions
and the goal is after every
meeting what was the question you can
kind of see emotionally they got hung up
on how do I enter that into my story so
that it's answered that's super simple
right but n enough people do this what
were the questions that they got hung up
with and I felt like I spent too much
time explaining myself how do I
incorporate that into the store in the
deck so that question doesn't come up it
gets right because the whole goal in a
if you get an hour or 30 minutes if it's
an hour get through the store in 25
minutes ideally so that the rest is just
discussion right it's just to get
through but if you're all the way an
hour 58 minutes and you're barely going
to the last
slide it's not going to work you have to
finish early which means you're you were
concise 20 slides 25 minutes ideally 17
16 slides 25 minutes like you know
you're just coming it through and then
you're inviting questions when you know
they
layups but if you get questions they're
like I don't know what about this what
about this oh you know well I used
figure out put that in the story early
answer it put it in the deck and the
goal is early investors that you
wouldn't take money from or really small
checks they're G to you're going to they
all kind of think alike to be honest so
they'll have the same questions answer
that and then second thing slow
investors so there's slow yeses and fast
yes
investors again I've pitched every
single firm every I know every GP at
every firm I know the personal I know
the slow people and the fast people you
pitch the slow people first obviously
because it's a it's a horse at the end
of the at the end of the cycle I call 30
days give yourself 30 days to pitch 30
days to close going back to the three
points that up to the right whatever
those three data points that you do you
spend 30 days getting it there but you
got to make sure for the next 60 they
continue to go up and to the right okay
I repeat the next 60 here's why the fomo
update 30 days why are you raising well
you know it used to take this long and
then this long but the last 30 days it's
like it's really exitting it's working
it's working it's working so you know I
don't so I should raise some money
while I'm pitching during the follow-ups
that week next week there's reasons for
the followup oh my God you know we met
two weeks ago and I told you that
conversion funnel and retention went
from here to here now it's
this fomo starts kicking in does that
make sense and then term sheet diligence
is 30 days it better keep going because
you won't get to the last right money in
the bank is what you need
30 days of grinding that data 30 days as
it's coming up you're pitching every
week there's something interesting new I
feel like I'm missing out it's it's
going to get away from me I give you
term sheet I feel good we're talking the
data and then things are still feel
going up during that if it's still going
up I might start trying to bring more
people into the round right like get me
motivated get me into the story so
that's a really important thing over the
next 90 over 90 days slow investors fast
investors there are some people who were
like yes let's go but you don't want
that yes now you want it when everyone
else is at the same right imagine a
horse race some horses start off slow
some fast let slow ones goes first fast
ones catch up so that you're all kind of
finishing up close at the same time your
negotiation window for a term sheet is
at most two weeks you are rude and an
if all of a sudden you're like I
gave you a trim sheet and you just don't
answer well here's how you slow game the
term
sheet very simple let's get to know each
other hey this is marriage can we go out
to dinner oh I can't this week next week
like think about the things of like you
you you gotta you have a week two weeks
Max but you cannot just sit on ter sheet
because Bird in Hand right like what if
everybody else says no so you but you
want them all getting to the same point
and all sudden you can start if you want
to get to the point of negotiation
otherwise I will say this do not over
optimize for Price start off a binary
when I say that it either exits or it
does not exit you did not start this
company because he wants a job for the
next 91 years making 12 125,000 a year
like
right the difference at the
endgame is if you made a $100
million well if I didn't take that
delution I would have made1 $1 million
it doesn't matter if you really mattered
you wouldn't live in New York
you'd go to
Florida true so think of that delution
so people focus so much do the
spreadsheet I always encourage Founders
to do this they're like oh 30% delusion
is too much I really 25 it doesn't make
a difference do a personal spreadsheet
your Equity over rounds c a b c d
e at the end it ends up being like 1 to
2% it's not that big of a deal right so
the best investors at the table because
they will help you their job is to help
you raise the next round the next round
the next round because you are always be
raising always always always be raising
right it's like ABC is always be
charging always be closing always be
raising so it the pace is they're really
important if you want this Collective
pressure at the end
I'm also talking to this firm I'm also
talking to this firm and once I know
you're talking a lot of firms and
everyone have to finish I want to close
if I know I'm the only investor at the
front I get to
negotiate I slow down my decision
process it's ball control it's ball
control You Never Let It Go um obviously
it helps to have a good product a good
company like it gives you the data it
does all these things the early stage
look water in a can it's the story The
story and belief the team right and some
things that will tell the story of why
now advisories sometime work I can't it
depends on the investors some investors
love that you have advisors I hate it
because it's unless it's real
right if it's somebody I know or
somebody who truly has that Insight or
has the connections that can accelerate
that business it's the cheat code so and
so is on my board so and so personally
invested so and so I used to work for so
and so like last night's dinner the
moment he told me he was on found team
butcher box and then he's building this
company Rel I'm like yeah let me give
you money like no yeah I know I love
that company it's storytelling but it's
understanding the business it's like oh
why this person oh he he's done it been
there for one of the fastest scaling
companies I know in the Commerce and
space the world used to look at this
they struggle through all these things
he helped figure all this stuff out
realize well that should just be a
separate company and if that's a
separate company here's the benefit for
everybody else oh the world used like
this now with this give me money because
I'm building this simple like L is
that's it that's the story and you just
want to give that person money it's not
about the numbers
so let's say that you're great at this
and it works
um now all of a sudden all these Venture
funds want
access oh and I've seen this one time I
was working on something and it was the
number one app in the app store and it
was right yes I knew it don't forget
that would only be yeah and so Venture
capitals were literally sending this
true story a pie to the office with a
note that says we would love to get a
piece of the
pie real clever I mean like that's the
that was going on right I've had I
have no story where like they'll they'll
send the private plane the whole thing
yeah they they will show up they I mean
when it's game time and there's
competition between especially the major
firms they will pull every single thing
out of the repertoire to impress a
Founder Etc how do
you enjoy the perks but also balance not
getting caught up emotionally and
potentially making a bad decision or
going with a uh investor that might not
be the best one out of those that are
interested so investors the whole your
job as a Founder is obviously the fund
the company but honestly it spend more
time on thinking
about what's the possibility of this
person being net
negative okay like
boards the board their job to remind you
is to decide is this CEO doing their job
and should they get
fired board meeting this is what I'm
going to tell you this is how the
company's doing this is what we're going
to do before now in the next board
meeting next board meeting I told you
what I was going to do and this is what
we did if you three St your out if you
show up to the board three times and you
didn't do what you said you're going to
do time to go so remember that so I do
take that seriously it's a marriage so
spend the time doing diligence I it's
crazy that not enough people check
references like truly not the references
they tell you find everybody they said
look people be behave the
way they
are all the time so find the people that
they aren't toing you about and there
are stories we all know who they are you
just got to find so I spend the time of
like who truly loves your song right
going back to music obsessed with the
song as your playlist truly can like
understand
you and want to invest not because of
they want to make money we can all make
money somewhere but they truly want to
be part of the journey but more
importantly they're not and
there's moments there will be moments in
the business where the highs are highs
as you know as a Founder the lows are
low and you want a person who's going to
be supporting you and not just thinking
about the money because the moment they
start thinking about money they don't
care about you and they make the the
worst decisions they're pushing you out
of the business and they start pushing
to make decisions in the business that
are the net negative so it's it's one of
these things when yes great firms all
this bidding war spend time with it
spend time who's joining the board
that's like my only advice just in due
diligence for the love of God so you and
I have talked on the diligence side uh
the best Founders to talk to in an
Investor's portfolio to get an honest
assessment is go find the ones that
didn't work yeah because you basically
see the downside and then the second
thing is never believe the first bad
story but listen to the second one right
like like everyone whether you're a
Founder an investor whatever everyone
just didn't get along with someone
didn't like someone they you know took
something personal whatever but if you
hear it twice twice didn't pay attention
yeah yeah a lot of negative stories are
just personal vendettas they said no so
they're now so like no if they did real
deep dark deep cut like that's
stuff you got to find out about um
otherwise enjoy it while it lasts but
remember that firm on that round their
job is to help you get to the next round
their job is to help you recruit people
their job is to open up the doors and
help accelerate the business we live in
a world now the it's really interesting
to me part of the story your moot this
is the last thing I I told for about the
the world's changed this
year I didn't think of it as much before
but I do think about all the time now in
the world of AI I don't know how to code
but I can proba clone every startup in
here in a
weekend right think about that like
whatever product you have like PP and I
probably this weekend we can clone it
literally with chat GPT the UI The
Experience Etc and I don't so what well
how do you win right what's the mo the
mo is so much more important so in a way
the advisory stuff does kind of help
right well I have access to this right I
have dis I have exclusive API access
here or I already have customer base
here or so and so is investing in the
largest distributor on the Eastern
Seaboard for this like that's the mo
otherwise you I can just think about
whatever you're pitching trust me
there's H it used to be maybe one or two
maybe another y company now it's like
100 companies in the exact same thought
you have it's not that original it's
really not someone else's cloning so now
the decision is like okay so much more
now goes into why
you versus this person and all these
other hundred people who are using chat
GPD built the same thing why you and
then what's the
mo exclusive relationship with this
Kaiser to roll out my sass off whatever
it is like it's got to have some in
there it's going to be a little bit
harder these days the only other thing
I'll add before we end is um I'm
surprised I've spent recently with two
different Founders a bunch of
fundraising meetings and there was two
kind of reminders right if you haven't
done it in a while one every single
Venture capitals will show up unprepared
like maybe late right but they get on
they haven't looked at your product yet
maybe they looked at the deck and you'd
be shocked because you're like oh I'm
going to pitch them for money and like
this is like you know you literally
blocked this out you prepared you did
all the stuff it's like the most
important meeting of the day
unfortunately you're one of many pitches
and so you have to be prepared for them
to be like so like how does the product
work whether that's sharing the screen
whether it's having the screenshots like
you have to anticipate some of this
which I think you were kind of
mentioning but the second thing is uh
you can't have the same exact pitch for
every single investor and so it can take
you 10 minutes if you know you're
meeting with ex partner at a venture
firm go on their Twitter account see
what they've been talking about go look
at their blog post go look at the
industry trends show up and and guess
what they told you the answers to the
test they're interested in Creator e
economy our SAS tool has a really big
thing in the greater economy right there
and you can talk through it but the more
that you kind of relate it to what
they're interested in obviously they're
going to spend more time on it yeah
remember one of the things about when
you're talking investors it I like some
7 8,000 every round I've ever done I've
done I'm somewhere like 150 rounds of
Health raise each round on average is a
100 nose Okay 70 to 100 nose for every
single yes okay it just you average that
out so just you got to keep at it but in
every story y know Ryan at flexport I
remember his seed round was done his
board member Roy bahat is a good friend
of mine he's like he help he needs
helped raising a nobody wants to give
him money
I'm like okay
I I sat down with them here's how did
the world do oh it's green screens oh
God it all of shipping Logistics world
is green screens right and show the
video of literally on the screen what a
green screen people don't know what that
is it's like oh really what are you
doing your beautiful web UI software oh
okay duh like that should like that
pitch alone the whole world is working
on literally greenpen text based
Logistics and you're bringing a visual
interface where you can track chips all
over the world and tell you where the
product is that's the pitch they raised
a b round struggles again come back in
it it it's it was just storytelling Flex
fors now you know $50 billion doll
company every story every founder has
that story it was always about just how
to tell that story the pitch it's just
is very slight tweak it has to be simple
right what was flexport well the whole
world sh on green screens UI this like
10 years ago that should work what did
they do right it's not complicated you
don't need to do the intricacies and use
all these web terminology like
forget the termin what does the product
do and let me visualize it and so that I
can tell the story to my partners and
understand it and give you money ladies
and gentlemen Peter
fam